what happens when five male cadavers are  put through scp-914  dr grangin decided to find out the first  cadaver was placed in 914 on the setting  rough the output was a pile of human  limbs organs and bones all separated via  apparent tearing and heat dr grenigan  described this as unsettling the next  cadaver was run through on course what  emerged was a pile of human remains with  the organs and bones removed via a  cutting tool and the skin nervous system  digestive system and circulatory system  were removed with no damage at all the  third cadaver was placed on one to one  though the cadaver that went in was  caucasian the one that came out was an  asian man the next cadaver went in on  fine it emerged with scp-008  inside of it the body was immediately  destroyed the final cadaver was placed  on the setting very fine the output was  green slime with the properties and  chemical structure of scp-447-2  the o5 council declared that no more  cadavers were to be tested in scp-914